On October 29th 2010, Jeremy Lin became the first Chinese-American...
...to play in a regular season NBA game.
The second son of Taiwanese immigrants, Gie-Ming and Shirley Lin,...
...Jeremy learned how to play basketball from his father who was a big NBA fan.
But not everyone in the family thought it was something he should pursue.
No one else really played basketball besides my family and so it was kind of taboo for a little bit and,...
...you know, with my grandma she was kind of always trying to influence me to not play.
And then, you know, once we realized this is something I love doing,...
...I'm having fun doing it and I can go play at the next level then, more people started supporting.
He continued to improve, and in 2006, led Palo Alto High to a 32-1 record...
...and an upset of nationally ranked Mater Dei in the Division 2 state championship game.
Despite being named player of the year by virtually every California publication,...
...he did not receive a single scholarship offer.
I think a lot of it was me being underdeveloped physically.
At that time, I was 170 pounds and I was just very raw.
And then, you know, me being Asian-American, I don't know how much that had to do with it,...
... but I'm sure it had something to do with it.
While Harvard does not provide athletic scholarships,...
...Jeremy was offered a chance to play there and accepted.
He excelled on the court despite having to put up with racist taunts...
...like being told to "Go back to China" and being called a "Chink."
You know, it was just some that got under my skin at the very beginning.
It was really frustrating but I just had to learn how to deal with it...
...as time went by for me to be able to be more mentally strong...
...and not get distracted or angered so easily.
Jeremy was twice named first team all Ivy League.
As the team's leading scorer during the senior season, he led Harvard to its best record ever.
Still, he wasn't taken in the 2010 NBA draft.
Dallas did sign Jeremy to its summer league team and he made the most of his opportunity...
...when he outplayed the overall number one pick, Kentucky's John Wall.
His performance against Wall got him contract offers from the Mavericks and Lakers,...
...but he chose to sign with his hometown team, the Golden State Warriors.
A devout Christian, Jeremy needed his faith to help him deal with the pressure...
...from the media and the Asian community.
Shot clock at five.
Jeremy jumper, Jeremy Lin off the bench!
How good has he been here in this quarter?
So far, the racist remarks he heard in college have not followed him to the NBA.
That's what I was really shocked about.
I don't think I heard one Asian taunt from an opposing fan or player all year actually so...
...I think a lot of other players in the NBA actually went out of their way...
...to say congratulations and different things like that and so...
...I think the NBA, you know, is like a big family.
I think all the guys are friends with each other and for the most part and...
...people respect what other people are doing and so that was really inspiring...
...and a nice change of pace for me.
Jeremy's faith was tested when he was sent down to the Warriors' developmental league team in Reno.
Being as that was another blessing in disguise, you know,...
...I remember when I first got sent down I felt like the world had ended...
...and I was like "No, don't do that. Don't send me down there."
But looking back, it was absolutely necessary.
I took three trips down there and that was the best thing that could happen to me...
...in terms of my development as a player in my first year in the league.
Playing with a renewed confidence, Jeremy finished the season strong with the Warriors.
At 6'3, 200 pounds, he has the size to play point guard in the NBA.
But to get more minutes, he'll need to put in some work.
In just one season, Jeremy has been able to break some old stereotypes...
...about Asian-Americans being unable to play sports at the professional level.
But he knows there will always be doubters.
You know, that's a stereotype that I'm going to have to fight for the rest of my life...
...but I understand that and it's something that I embrace.
The more I can do to break that stereotype, I'd love to do that.